the you shouldn't do this Ollie it's Roy
you see the real question is who do I
gotta bring the pain till where are you
guys keeping my suit
you okay Kate hey I always kidnap to
here two years ago I think I don't know
wait what's your name
Arland
[Music]
everybody is Charlie and Roy Harper is
back finally he gets rekt in this
episode just looking at some of these
preview images it looks like he's just
gonna get raked over the coals by
Richard dragons men
if you've ran into the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a schedule update for the DC TV
episodes in the next couple of weeks so
we'll talk about that at the end of the
video because they just came back from a
break but they're going on another break
after next week's episode I know it's a
little weird but the description for the
Roy episode just reads Oliver and Thea
are shocked they're shocked that Roy
Harper is back in Star City however when
they discovered the circumstances of
Roy's return Oliver and Thea realized
that Roy is in trouble and jumped to
save him black siren makes a shocking
decision which we kind of saw at the end
of last week's episode like she's going
to be impersonating earth one Laurel
Lance the most famous dead person in
Star City according to Stephen Amell
earlier this year when he was
interviewed about this so a couple
really big things I mean everybody's
just really happy to get Roy back but
obviously they made a couple big moves
behind the scenes and it implies what's
gonna be happening with black Sirens
character in the future if Black Canary
doesn't throw her off a cliff
I believe episode 15 is the only Roy
Harper episode Stephen Amell did say
that there was a special guest star for
episode 18 and he didn't want it to be
announced because it was supposed to be
a big surprise but he was kind of
worried that the network was gonna spoil
it ahead of time by publicly announcing
them I don't know who that character is
but it does sound like it might wind up
being someone from one of the other DC
TV shows but because there's gonna be
like a two week break after next week's
episode is gonna be a while before we
see that but I think your enjoyment of
this past week's episode episode 14 just
hinges on your ability to believe the
actions of the characters so far Quentin
turning his kidnapper badge and taking
black siren to that cabin in the woods
and then police detective Black Canary
wanting to commit first-degree murder
like I'm gonna hunt her down then scream
in her face til her brains turn to jelly
just like she did the vigilante there
wasn't really big birds of prey Easter
Egg because now you have black siren
versus Black Canary so of course there's
probably gonna be a couple of birds of
prey Easter eggs that ain't black siren
used when she went to withdraw that
money from the bank was sue George I
that means
little bird it's from birds-of-prey
issue number one so I'm expecting more
birds of prey Easter eggs as we continue
this Black Canary versus black siren arc
because Katie Cassidy's gonna stay on
the show so obviously they're gonna keep
going at each other
another really big thing is there's
gonna be impersonating earth-1 Laurel
that the entire city knew about when she
died at the hands of damian darhk--
that's why Stephen Amell was saying that
she's the most famous dead person in
Star City she was held up as an example
for why the city's gone as [ __ ] in why
it's so dangerous to become a vigilante
because if you're not fully prepared
like you haven't gone through all of
your paces before you hit the streets
you're gonna wind up dead the blowback
from that is something that we're gonna
find out about over the next couple of
episodes like Stephen Amell was just
teasing like wouldn't that be
interesting if she were to come back
into the limelight the earth one version
of Laura like how would people deal with
that but obviously we as the audience
know that it's really black siren
masquerading as her so the whole idea is
it's like will she just continued to
keep up this facade if there really is a
path to redemption for her character
depending on whether or not you believe
that based on the scenes she's had so
far like it really does sound like she
doesn't totally care about Quentin but
like a little part of her does otherwise
she would have killed him already it was
that whole scene where they talked about
her daddy issues we know a little bit
about her backstory on earth to like her
version of Oliver is dead her version of
Quentin was a worst version of arc
Quentin she just lived a much harder
life which has driven her to do the
things that she's done there was also
that wild dog mr. t reference I pity the
fool he literally calls mr. terrific mr.
t you've got us back on track mr. t I
know there were a lot of questions
earlier this year and last year about
Roy Harper possibly being a character
during Titan season one but they haven't
said anything official about that like
they're still in the middle of shooting
Titans episodes and they've really only
revealed a handful of characters like
the Doom Patrol brother blood Church of
blood they haven't made any official
announcements about Roy Harper Donna
Troy or any of the other bigger Titans
comic book characters that they hope to
introduce in future seasons so Colton
Haynes seems like he's mostly busy
filming TV in Los Angeles and they
filmed Titans in Toronto so I think
unless there's a big change or they use
him for like a super big arc during
season two if they do Roy Harper
they'll probably recast the character
but I don't think it's gonna be a really
big issue like when it comes to
crossover characters like Deathstroke
and his family are big Teen Titans
characters obviously the Titans TV show
will use some of them at some point but
arrow spent all these years developing
Manu Bennett son of the character I
don't think that Titans is going to be
using Deathstroke anytime soon so it's
like you know the characters that
already exist in the arrow burst I don't
think there's gonna be a lot of
duplication right out of the gate so
like you're mostly going to be seeing
brand new characters like the Doom
Patrol is the best example of that we've
never seen a live-action version of them
on the arrow verse and you have to
remember that Jeff Jones is the person
that everybody goes to when they want to
use a big comic book character in Jeff
Jones's co-writing the Titans TV show so
he's the guy that knows which shows are
using which characters so for the most
part they try to keep from stepping on
each other's shows only after arrow or a
couple of the other shows go off the air
do I think that they're gonna free up
some of the big comic book characters to
go on to Titans so as we get more
information about that I'll just do new
videos don't worry there's gonna be a
lot of Titan stuff happening later this
year but that series won't premiere to
like the very end of the summer so you
don't need to worry about too much of
that right now
so just a reminder about the arrowverse
episodes so actually I'm looking at a
different schedule here and it tells me
what's going on with the flash - so both
arrow in the flash are brand new next
week like we have the enter flash time
flash family episode then it gets a
little bit weird so right after next
week's arrow episode the Roy episode
arrow goes on break for two weeks the
flash goes on break for one week after
episode 16 so next week there's a new
flash episode episode 15 then we get
episode 16 of the flash the week after
that then the flash goes on break for it
looks like maybe just one week then that
very last week in March everything comes
back then I believe for the rest of the
seasons they finish sharing all their
episodes with no breaks and then when
Legends ends its run that Monday night
slot goes back to Supergirl so if you
watch Supergirl you're wondering where
that is it'll come back after legends
finishes airing its episodes and just
air right into the summer so Supergirl
will go a little later into the summer
because it's been on break for so long
but that's about it I'll be doing bonus
videos wall stuff is on break just like
I did but it was on break during the
Olympics so don't worry they're just
going out of production hiatus it's just
because the last batch of episodes is
really special effects heavy for all the
TV shows so they need extra time to
finish the episodes which is why they
build in this production break
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Timothy Adams please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for that Flash Teen
Titans Easter Egg from this past week
and click here to learn about all those
big infinity war things that they
announced last night thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight